I want one only et was on set as
Bachelorette Hannah brown hit the rugby
fields with her men in Newport Rhode
Island for an intense group date
we got the scoop on where Hannah's
feelings were really hitting hard you
were gonna pick right now just three
guys who are kind of sticking out in
your mind who would they be
I had a one-on-one with Jed yesterday
and we had a great time I also have
really enjoyed Connor s we've had some
time together and there's a few other
ones that are really up there - who are
they I know you're there in your head
and I don't want to say everyone because
that those are two that I've had a lot
of I've had more time with and really
got to know their hearts and so I'm
really excited about continuing all of
them and then there are a few other men
here that I'm really interested to get
to know more about and spend more time
with okay like let me tell you something
my baby boy Garret he is getting after
it
it's in our blood you know to be
champions so roll tide
very impressive Garrett's not you and
Connor having a couple moments how into
Connor are you Connor is great he's
obviously very handsome but he is so
sweet and comforting to me and so really
like Connor
excited for him I also saw you and Luke
P chat a little bit no he got the first
impression rose
mm-hmm Luke P has always like definitely
made sure that he has shown that he's
here for me so we always have good
conversations throughout the day and
also really excited about that
relationship to the Bachelorette airs
Monday nights on ABC